thank you very much cole anthony you did
it again
what is it what is it about you at the
end of a basketball game my friend
i do this man i do this i do this i was
brave for this
i i ain't detected
that's great well if you're going to do
that if you're going to hit the game
winner
that's what you got coming your way we
got wet headsets we got happy teammates
hey hey if you're good if you're going
to do that if you're going to make game
winners they're going to do that to you
that's
what i'm just i'm scared to walk into
the locker room because i feel like
they're going
to do something dangerous but um yeah i
just i i do this
i live for these end of moments and
games it's just it's crunch time what i
said
two days two games ago that's my time i
want to get that showing for my team so
just had to go get it done and
just brief shout out to everybody on the
magic man we came we fought today we're
down 15 coming into the halftime man
dudes did not give up i love this team
man
love this city let's go hey man at the
end of the minnesota game you said let
the ball come to me because i know i'm
going to make it
was it the same feeling tonight colts
yeah yeah
yeah come on yeah but take us into the
huddle what happened what was the play
and
was that exactly what was drawn up well
man yeah we had a few plays out and we
had played jonah before that if the ball
had come to us when uh
they was reviewing that joint and i was
i was honestly in my head like i just
really just want to iso
not even a lot of you i wanted ice i
just knew i got someone on the island it
wasn't going to be safe
that that's that's real what i knew was
happening but that was the play we drew
up came off that scene i had my scene i
had uh kind of
like he has game time trying to get this
money